hey wassup guys my name is a Turner and
welcome to episode 18 of network chapron
I mean okay so today we are going to
talk about basically how to send
different types of packets okay and
these aren't gonna be different types of
packets in the sense that something's
gonna be you know really different in
code but the data that we send we're
actually gonna prefix it with a certain
identifier so that we can then say okay
called this is a a connection packet
this is a disconnection packet this is a
whatever packet okay um so the idea is
just just to help you guys understand
this the idea is that we have we you
know as a client as being the client
side of this entire program we want to
kind of you know send the server
different types of packets so the idea
is if we send something like hey man
that's gonna be a message right but then
what what happens if we want to send the
server a connection request so we we
basically want to be like okay hey
server this is me this is my IP address
I want you to add me to the arraylist
here of clients okay how do we send a
connection that says your server what up
connect me okay how do we send something
like this well we could actually send
that and then match it to me like a gave
the client says this connection but more
logically we need somehow to
differentiate it from just a simple
message and the way that we're going to
do that is by using a forward slash and
then we're actually going to use
whatever the hell letter we want
followed by another folder slash
followed by the actual message okay so
we're prefixing it with full slash safe
for slash okay and C's gonna stand for
connection right for this connection we
might use D and for I don't know some
kind of other information pack what we
want use I doesn't matter what you use
you can use your you can use Cherno here
it doesn't matter because again we're
gonna actually create this structure so
if we set it to C let's start with that
there's gonna be a connection packet so
after that we might want to send we
don't need to send apart and the UM and
the address remember because that's
going to be sent like the packet will
know where it's coming from so that's
fine but what we might want to do is
like modernist and a client idea from
and be like you know maybe this is our
client ID and then that will actually
send it send it through so that's one
way of doing it okay
and we're gonna talk about how we can do
that today so let's delete these
comments and get back into our receive
method which is where we receive our
packet so once we've received our packet
we kind of want to process it so what I
like to do is make a a private method
here called process along along with our
actual data so string will be used okay
and then if we just hover our mouse over
that in fact let's do it slow way so you
can see exactly what's going on so let
me just scroll this up a bit so a
private void process string message I
guess we'll call it packet all right so
this is going to process a packet of
data so essentially what we want to do
here is we want to kind of have like a
you know a bunch of if statements so if
you know if our packet here dot starts
with and that's the often awesome thing
about Java like it has all these methods
already in built for you well so do a
lot of other languages but anyway so if
packet starts with you know C then we
know it's a connection packet so in that
case what I wanted in fact this is a bad
way of doing it let's let's not send
this through let's just send the packet
through so let's pop this down and we'll
change this to a data ground packet and
we will change this to be okay with what
is the process let it go packet okay and
then all this stuff is what we use
before so we're gonna have to delete
this because it's not no longer relevant
but nevertheless processed packet okay
so this is what's gonna happen
basically you know we receive a packet
which is you know contained within a
byte array of data and we're just we're
forwarding that packet across to this
process method which is where we do
everything so what we get that we get
the bytes back into a string and so on
so if packet does start with if string
now if string dot
would say then we could choose to do
something we can we can basically you
know as we had here as we had here
clients don't add new server client yarn
blah blah we'd actually go ahead and
said clients oops
clients dot add new server client now
the name this is important this is one
of the things that we want to send in
the packet okay so I'll talk about that
in a minute but we basically need to put
a name here we also need packet or get
addresses now actually just gonna be
packet address and packet dot get port
and 50 was the ID okay so we'll just oh
that's what we need to talk about we'll
do that next episode okay we'll talk
about a unique identifier because that's
an important topic well what am i doing
that mmm okay yeah so we'll do something
like this now this is a good point
actually that just came up and else you
know if it's nothing else if we because
we were only added to say right now as a
unique kind of identifier if it's
anything else then you know I guess some
it I guess it is just an actual method
an actual message so we could just print
our string to the console okay just just
to see what's going on
right so now that we are now that we
have this unique identify what we want
to have here maybe is something like
okay well let's send not only just a
connection packet here but let's also
send the name of the client that's good
idea alright so what we can do then is
or I guess the best way to do this it
depends really how much daughter you
have you might want to have a bunch of
data you know separated by dots it's
really like the possibilities here are
endless guys you're gonna have to decide
for yourselves what you want what you
don't want but I think the only thing we
need to send at the moment and you guys
let me know if you think of anything
else is probably just a name
write the name and the fact that we do
want to connect because the IP address
and the port which was the other two
details were neither contained within
the pack and automatically because
that's how the UDP protocol works so um
we don't need to do that manually
luckily well not like I mean it wouldn't
be too hard to do it manually but
there's it just obviously is not
necessary at all so we've got a new
client great
let's grab the name so the way we could
do this is pretty uh it's not through
hard so if we grab our string which is
our data here and we could actually I
think yeah if we go substring and begin
index being three probably and and and
and index obviously being a string
length that would get the name I'm
pretty sure okay and obviously I screw
this up I know I didn't like alright
okay so this will hopefully work again
I'm not hard percent sure because I
don't know these string methods off my
heart but will just print it out the
console so I can say okay so that's good
that should be good so now we need to go
back to our client and not serve a
client but client and when we actually
do get this send connection to get to
get bytes what we need to do is we've
got this address and port stuff here but
all we need to do is really send name
and of course all this brings this
brings another little thing to the table
which I'm not going to talk about today
but let's just send us a plus name okay
so that that means it's a connection
packet and name is obviously just our
name so let's let's start up a server
here by hitting let me just bring up
this console here let me just start up a
server by hitting the debug button or
actually it's gonna start at the login
screen which is good and then we'll go
to server main and start that as well to
start our awesome server on port 81 1 2
so Y on localhost 8 1 9 to login
alright awesome so it added it obviously
and you can see here that it actually
printed yarn which was our name so we
did actually pass that string correctly
alright so that's going to be this
episode of network Shepherd I mean if
you guys did enjoy the episode please
hit like button tomorrow or well
tomorrow I'm getting ahead of myself
next episode which might or might not be
tomorrow depending on how many likes
this video guess by the way 200 likes an
episode tomorrow or otherwise I'm gonna
punish you guys and you know I'm really
just probably gonna study for exams
instead but now we'll talk about a
yeah how to generate unique random
numbers because we need a unique random
number here random next in isn't gonna
comment because even though there is a
minuscule like one in two billion chance
of getting the same idea it is still
possible so we're gonna kind of it'll
eliminate that so we'll talk about
unique numbers next time all right later
guys